[Music]
well
i have a story here that has to do with
two mom influencers who
had a falling out because uh
they were friends right and so this one
she had a newborn
baby daughter named and she named her
baby with the eye
and then uh oh two years later
her friend named her daughter baby with
the y
and so they had a falling out because
her friend
copied her baby's name that is a copy
that is a copy though can we be
that is [ __ ] hilarious how are these
like teen moms what the [ __ ]
this is so high school bro so how dare
you name my
that's my baby's name that's my baby no
that's my baby well i like the name you
don't own baby
mine's with the y but it does happen
enough where when ant was about to have
a second kid he did ask us because he
was getting close to
what we were originally going to name
taika and then he was like can we name
him that
yeah we're like we're like we don't give
a [ __ ] you see the seinfeld episode
about seven
no oh well george was gonna name his kid
seven
and then the like they stole his name
yeah
it's a thing it's a thing yeah i mean
there was a guy that was gonna name him
his kid that what our we had already
planned for years on the american and
yeah but what about that was the big
deal did you guys have a falling out we
did not we
we told him he can do whatever he wants
but he decided not to do it just just
because he
said it like this you do whatever you
want yeah you make your decision okay
you do your thing you do whatever you're
gonna do
you know we're all adults here we're all
adults yeah we're all adults you can
make your own decisions can't you we're
all real friends
so yeah yeah i don't give a [ __ ] yeah
you look pretty happy about it i'm gonna
do it
yeah name whatever you wanna do yeah we
don't go [ __ ] these people here
so one of them is named sasha benz
and she's 33 years old and the other one
and she's the one that named
the daughter baby first and then no one
puts baby in a corner
yeah there there's a lot of that in this
article and then um
and then uh the the friend her name
is jessica hart and she's a 34 year old
victoria's secret model who's newly
engaged to her nascar driving baby daddy
james
really good really good race car driver
and a lingerie model good opening
interesting yeah can we see a picture of
her make sense
no she doesn't have any oh [ __ ] sorry
we'll show you the baby are they both
victoria's secret models and then
they're like battling it out well they
call her a blogging one so this is
jessica i think we can figure out who's
who
you don't [ __ ] everybody in this room
you know you [ __ ] are saying the same
[ __ ]
i didn't i i didn't even look on the
left one i don't know
really you don't know who the model is
look at just let's look at that
sometimes you can take a really good
picture of someone and really bad
pictures of someone
but that's true but look at the posing
look at the posing
i don't know i don't know about modeling
posing how can you tell from this
picture
all right well i'm a [ __ ] i just see
two i can't tell at all geo
they look the same is that your cigar so
which one i see
two beautiful women who could easily be
models that's what i see [ __ ] off
so this is jessica this is sasha she
named her baby baby first
she did it after they had a falling out
but as of now
apparently they've made up and it's no
big deal
and why do we wait why do we how do we
know that yeah why do we know this story
um i don't even know she blogged about
it
they're reporting it and she blogged
that she was angry i don't know
i don't know i do know that it was a
source a source
told the media outlets that there was
some sort of falling out
maybe because the names are just
interesting like baby
yeah exactly well that's that's actually
so it was taylor and taylor or something
that's already been around or like that
sarah
was talking about too like oh that's one
thing that's pretty funny that they had
a falling out because they named their
kid the same thing but also
they named their kid babe yeah that's
odd
it's like if gwyneth paltrow's best
friend named her kid apple
right right now i'm glad you brought up
apple because in the article they talk
about that
how gwyneth paltrow and chris
her husband whatever at that time um
martin
so they actually asked their friends
because their friends
had a kid named apple first so they
asked them like hey is this cool and
they're like yeah it's cool so then
that's
apple was actually used not this
comparison is apples to apples
you set that [ __ ] up the whole time
you're an [ __ ]
oh man you think they did that when the
kid's name was like john
probably not hey is it cool if i named
my son john as well yeah because i know
you're not you know i've been wanting to
use john for a long time and i told you
in confidence and i told you i didn't
want to share the name and you're going
to use john brown
i'm going to write with j j o n though
you have j o h in wow
bro it's too close what if i'm calling
my son john and your
son's over like what do we do oh yeah by
the way
the model that recently named the baby
baby or her baby baby
she said that she had all ever since a
kid ever since watching what's the movie
dirty dancing
driver no dirty dancing yes ever since
watching that movie when she was a child
she always had the name baby on her
babies list
show me proof where are the receipts and
then that she actually had to convince
the baby daddy to let them name her be
i get why i hate the name and that she
could all
she could her daughter can shorten it to
bae if she wanted to
oh cut it out oh good thanks for the
solution mom rough
yeah but it might trend i thought they
named the baby after the movie baby
driver because the main character's name
was baby
i thought they were just dumb and they
just wanted to remember that it was a
baby
so you had to call what is that that's
good that's a baby oh yeah yeah just
just call it the same thing
like you know you got a dog just call it
a dog you know that's true person could
be a very unique
um baby name don't give it away nikki
don't just tell everyone what we're
gonna name her
i know our friend almost named that if
anyone else
don't take person from us don't do it
person green
that's funny so the first baby
one her name is baby blue benz oh jeez
that's her name baby blue benz that's
that is just a built-in douchebag name
like you're just you're a douchebag at
birth yeah also the dad he's an a dj
named oliver ollie
benz and then um
should have named it mercedes mercedes
benz
uh turns out that that chick is also a
model apparently but anyway so then
i gotta eat my words you're telling me i
gotta eat my [ __ ] words
so the other kids is rhythm wild benz
wilde with the y of course uh and then
the dot another daughter is haze heart
bends okay hey to each their own
i mean my business it ain't my kid we
had some basic ass names during
our childhood like it was us i mean
yeah tiffany
but were they basic when our parents
were naming us i got made
fun of them my i'm steven with the ph
though and it's
really fantastic because everyone calls
me every time one phone
and then they mistaken him for
bartholomew which is a pretty
basic era name for our parents
generation
i just remember the story with
bartholomew and all the hats
remember that story which one there was
a bartholomew with a bunch of hats as a
doctor whose
book i think anyway that's the first
time i heard that
he's barton i know but i would have
thought bartholomew oh that makes more
sense
yeah but i also might have thought bart
simpson which i didn't even put together
it's short for boss
cartoon came out
all right i'm gonna show you guys photos
of babies i bet they're cute as [ __ ]
because they're both models you know
you know what i mean so this is jessica
i didn't say they were ugly i just
you could tell which one was the model
which i [ __ ] was wrong
i couldn't tell because they should both
be models wow you i know you fill me up
this is the next driver guy
okay and then they're baby and then this
is the baby
baby baby
no no this is the new one imagine being
a grown-ass man named baby though
that's tight like a grandpa no no i
can't and it's a girl
oh these are both girls oh okay yeah and
then this is the other baby i would not
want people to call me
like if he's a guy trying to hit on me
hey baby i'd be like [ __ ] you could
shorten it to bae she says
dude imagine already having a pet name
just because he had he just talked she
could change her name
you know everyone can change their name
blue
a lot of kids have cause this is your
the og name with the
with the eye it'll be like call me this
like you by the time call me baby so
call me baby
hey i just met you this is crazy
we had two of my babe blue yeah they're
cool names
i guess i can't make fun too hard
because i have a cat named mama but it's
a cat no her name is cece you call her
mama
well she's named mama to me so on her
paperwork
it says cece well i haven't called her
cece one time nicknames are cool like
baby
is a great nickname nickname yeah i used
to have a dog named boy
well he wasn't my dog he was my stepdad
my first dog i named him joe so
we could be close because we both share
the same name oh we have a cat named joe
he pees all our stuff
yeah if he's in our head too if he's the
next pizza sounds like me i do like
i like he tests peeing boundaries a lot
i like to pee a lot gio's a cool name
thank you
giovanna that's a [ __ ] bold choice
she nailed it giovanna antoinette i
think
is that spanish yeah is it a spanish
name it's italian
oh yeah giovanni but during that time
the car the geo metro was around so when
i thought
i think of the car so it was geo that
owned a geo metro
wow wow yeah it must have been it was a
heavy dark time for me dude
so easy geo driving a geo metro yeah and
that's so easy to attack and she would
do her geometry
and she would collect geo pokemons and
she'd watch that geo
all day oh damn yeah i was consumed in
the life of geo and she took a geology
class
yes damn you've you figured it all out
and your favorite rock is a geode
geode and then something with the
geodude what's geo do pokemon i already
said that oh i don't know i'm sorry
you were ignored i thought i kind of
heard it but i forgot it's because i put
my pun blocker up
yeah just in case you just said a bunch
of buttons
but if you say them it's extra painful
though you know right now
with your look all i need to hand you is
a [ __ ] coors light
and yeah i got you dude i got it no it
has to go in your pocket right here
i'm in i'm in you
you should also like wrap me around
a destroyed car like i just drunk drove
into a tree
you could do that in the gum yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]